so yeah how was it for you and
Performing from your parents it was fun
uh my my parents and two of my brothers
came to the uh Dublin show which was uh
fun I think they were more excited to go
to Dublin than Wales but it didn't come
to Wales again to Dublin but actually
it's about it's about the same time to
get to each yeah because you can just
get the uh the ferry from North Wales
right right yeah uh over so it's pretty
easy to get there and I think they all
just like going to Ireland I mean
Ireland's nice so yeah how was it
performing uh in Wales
yeah Wales was cool I mean well the
Welsh crowd was definitely uh I think it
was a Monday it was definitely some
really loud people and then some people
who are very quiet and it was it was fun
trying to get their energy out of them
sometimes but it was a smaller show as
well too before yeah there was a small
show but they they were still loud at
times
um it was good I think I was definitely
more nervous performing in front of my
parents than in front of Welsh people
yeah Welsh people I'm like yeah let's
[__] go let's do it yeah
um but yeah and in front of my parents
it was it was interesting all right
because there's one part on the show
where we have to name a hentai category
we secretly like and uh that was what I
was nervous about as well yeah you
mention like a porn category ratio that
you like yeah yeah and I was like well
I shouldn't say MILF
so I I didn't say it was the only time I
ever didn't say milk yeah I was like all
right well it was funny she said what
did you say I said vanilla or something
yeah of course yeah because I did it on
London show as well missionary of course
marital yeah
because yeah they loved it though they
really liked it yeah because uh I think
what made me more nervous on the day of
like the London show was I had like the
guest list of like friends and family
and like in the most like big Asian
family way possible I get like a message
about like six hours before the show and
they were like oh a cousin just said
he's free uh he wants to come to the
show yeah go on your family was like 900
people and then like progressively they
were like oh wait another cousin is also
free oh another cousin's coming actually
and I I think I had like an extra six to
seven people just like progressively in
the day being like actually uh family
I'm free so dude it was crazy like
throughout the entire day it was just
like a posse of people just like rocking
up and I'm like what the [__]
it's like how many are there back here
yeah
um and you know a lot of them but I
pretty much every one of them uh did not
know anything about trash Chase or the
show
um I had I had one cousin that I had not
seen in about like a decade just because
we've always we'd like we've all he's
been living in different countries so
we've never kind of like matched up so
he was like actually on there on the day
and it was the first time I've seen him
in over a decade uh last time we'd kind
of like talked I did not do YouTube or
you know still I think this was like
still when I was in university yeah not
even this was like pre-bbc errors so
when he heard I was doing a show in
London he assumed it was nine and a half
pounds
your school band yeah he thought oh he
thought I was like doing a [__] band
performance in London you know we did we
did get our friends good kid to open for
us at the London show yeah should have
just got nine and a half pounds
yeah yeah so he was like oh what what
you're not doing a music show this isn't
a band what are you guys doing and I was
just like oh my God we have so much to
catch on how do I even begin to explain
what we're doing right now
comedy show yeah but I was impressed
because pretty much everyone enjoyed
themselves even if they have no interest
in anime manga or YouTube it's like I
think we when we were making the tour
that's one thing we said it's on the
America Tour thing as well we're like
yeah we just want to make sure that
anyone could watch it yeah yeah um but
if you're a fan of trash tasting yeah
there's like added bonuses right yeah
yeah but I think yeah knowing that our
parents really enjoyed really enjoyed
their time there uh I think also parents
like it's just kind of a cool experience
to get to go like backstage and then be
like hang out and just be like all right
go to your seat now someone will help
you you know yeah it's such a phonics I
think it's like a cool experience
because like I think a lot of people
just don't get to do that as well oh
yeah totally so I think my parents I
know my Mom and Dad loved that they were
like he was like what we get to have
free beer I was like yeah well it's
obvious it's not free but yeah it's free
for you it was a totally different
experience for me I had like my entire
family come back yeah I can't had like
40 people and I was like holy [__] and
it was just like at least a small Asian
family
and everyone's like let's take a picture
and I'm like okay how many different
combinations am I taking today ah okay
it was kind of ridiculous I was like oh
my God I was like God's family came out
like five people and I was like oh
that's nice and four more Thai people
came out yeah five more Thai people five
more types
I didn't even take them to the green
room because uh the queen room would not
fit my family so I just took them out
back even without your family two of the
green rooms were just completely full
I'm just like what the [__] yeah but uh
yeah that's why the London show meant a
lot to me and I'm glad to say that it's
uh went out really well yeah it's uh I'm
glad to see it I actually I actually
have a pretty funny story of something
that happened not during the tour but
this was like before the tour
so I get okay I get a message from my
mum right
so I got a message from my mom being
like all excited uh because my dad had
just come home and apparently he was
shopping in town uh and someone someone
looked at him and he was just like oh
that's an interesting shirt you're
wearing uh why why are you wearing the
shirt and uh he was like oh I'm uh my
son's a YouTuber and with zero context
but the the shop clerk was like oh is
your is she is your son gigock and he
was like yeah yeah how could you know
I'm like you took a picture and I was
like I I asked my mom mum how did he
know of that uh uh that my dad was in
town or how could he guess that I was
the son so this is the shirt that my dad
I was rude and I'll send this to you I
can't believe your dad wore that shirt I
can't believe he wore that says
he says uh says insert oppa here it is
uh one of my old shirts that uh one of
my old meme shirts that I had like just
lying about and my dad just like decided
to wear it and go into town when you're
dead rocked up to the show he's wearing
the the purple shirt I always oh he was
he was good he got that drip down hell
yeah he's like your number one fan oh he
is now yeah he's so on board I love it I
love how intuitive yeah every time we
get a new you must drop my dad's like
give me everything
uh one thing I wasn't nervous about
though was uh not my dad but my cousin
uh wanted to bring my nephew over and I
was like a very much warning my cousin
yo at certain points in the show please
take them out because because
yeah it is not appropriate uh for their
age
um but it was it was weird seeing how
you know it was oddly made me proud as
an uncle being like [__] he is really
[__] excited and like being able to
show him the bus I was like yeah oh [__]
that's what the tour bus was always like
I think impresses people the most
absolutely because it's just so it's so
hard to believe a bus can be so
comfortable yeah and like so I guess and
it's like you guys drive to different
countries
so it was like it was it was such like a
wholesome moment for me because normally
he's like a he's like a really shy kid I
kind of like me when I was a kid super
shy doesn't say much when he was on the
bus he was asking like million questions
oh it's so cute
that's so cute man yeah uh yeah honestly
amazing experience doing it in front of
my friends and family I think like this
it kind of felt like a lot of the tour
was like me like preparing for you know
performing in front of my friends and
family totally I'm sure for you as well
for the world show and Performing fun of
like your friends and family as well I
guess our first show was on from my
parents so I kind of was just like I
remember how to do this yeah no you guys
both questions luckily it all worked out
as a really fun show I mean Dublin's
just a great Dublin is a very fun city
to be in yeah the people are so fun
though yeah and I think uh yeah I was
just like I haven't seen uh I haven't
seen that much of my family all in one
place in a while so yeah